der Mann der Fitness für die breite
Masse zugänglich machte Rainer Schaller
Mister McFit ein selfmade Mann ein
Visionär ein Multimillionär aber er war
eben auch der Mann der die Duisburger
Loveparade organisierte die so tragisch
mit so vielen Toten endete nun ist
Schaller mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
tot er und seine Familie abgestürzt mit
einem kleinen Flugzeug in Costa Rica
zwei Leichen wurden bislang gefunden
darunter wohl der sechsjährige Sohn der
Familie Aaron doch die für die
Rekonstruktion des Absturzes so wichtige
Blackbox konnte bislang noch nicht
geortet werden die Bergungsmaßnahmen sie
laufen nur schleppend
am Tag nach dem furchtbaren Crash werden
Suchtrupps der nationalen Küstenwache
zunächst rasch fündig im Meer treiben
Wrackteile Sitzpolster Teile der
Tragflächen Öl Spuren sind sichtbar und
in dem schwimmenden trümmerteppich
werden erste menschliche Überreste
gefunden zwei Todesopfer laut den
Behörden ein Mann und deinen Junge doch
gestern am zweiten Tag nichts das
Innenministerium in der Hauptstadt San
José beantwortet mehrmalige bildanfragen
mit einem gebetsmühlenartigen es gibt
nichts neues es stimmt aber auch die
Suche nach den Überresten des
todesfluges der Deutschland und die Welt
geschockt hat läuft nicht mehr auf
vollen Hochtouren ab Sonntag 5 Uhr
morgens Ortszeit startet nur eine
einzige Suchmaschine vom 150 km
entfernten San José Boote der
Küstenwache laufen eher sporadisch aus
der limitierte Einsatz bleibt bis
Sonnenuntergang ergebnislos schlechtes
Wetter vor der Küste erschwert die Suche
so die Behörden was die Einsatzkräfte
aber am frustriert vom Hauptteil des
versunkenen Wracks fehlt weiter jede
Spur dort wird der Rest der Opfer
vermutet in einer winzigen Bucht nahe
der Container helfen in die Mond liegt
ein Stützpunkt der Garda Costas der
Küstenwache hier liegt das
Operationszentrum der Bergungsarbeiten
zu Wasser Bild erhält Zugang hier ist
einer der Orte der natürlich sehr
traurig und sehr makaber ist es ist ein
Einsatzort der Küstenwache hier in Costa
Rica und man sieht hier im Hintergrund
hinter mir die Teile die bereits
gefunden wurden nach dem Flugzeugabsturz
von Rainer Schaller und seiner Familie
man sieht hier einige Teile sehr
bedrückend natürlich Sitze
fragt Teile ein Teil des ein Teil des
Fensters verschiedene elektronische
Bauteile
hier teile des möglicherweise des
Leitsystems all das hat die Küstenwache
bei den Sucharbeiten bisher hierher
gebracht in diese kleine Bucht hier nahe
der Stadt Puerto schon die Sucharbeiten
laufen weiter aber es wird immer
schwieriger denn es gibt im Suchgebiet
starke Strömungen die die frakteile weit
abtreiben lassen und das Wrack der
Maschine wurde bisher immer noch nicht
gefunden im Gebäude der Kriminalpolizei
und Staatsanwaltschaft laufen
Untersuchungen über die Hintergründe der
schrecklichen Flugzeugabsturzes und auch
die schaurige Arbeit zur endgültigen
Identifizierung der Leichen die ersten
Vertreter von Schallers 4 im Imperium
sind eingetroffen treffen sich mit
Behördenvertretern sie wollen sich vor
Ort einen ersten Überblick verschaffen
ein Polizist berichtet über neue cremige
Details spricht von zahlreichen kleinen
Leichen Teilen noch am Samstag werden
sie in ein forensisches Labor gebracht
den a-proben sollen jetzt bei der
Identifizierung helfen Bild besucht doch
den geplanten Zielort der
schallerfamilie in Costa Rica die sich
auf einer Weltreise befunden hatte
eineinhalb Autostunden vom Flughafen in
Limone entfernt liegt das traumhafte
Dschungel Kongo Bongo 7 idyllisch
eingerichtete Ferienhäuser liegen der
verstreut im dicken Grün des Regenwaldes
die Schallers buchen zwei Nächte kommen
dort aber nie an
Weltreporter Herbert bauernnebel ist für
uns in Limon Herbert gibt es inzwischen
neue Erkenntnisse was kannst du uns
sagen
ja tatsächlich es war ein enttäuschender
Tag der heutige Sonntag es wurde gesucht
von 35 morgens bis fünf am Nachmittag
beim Einbruch der Dunkelheit und
tatsächlich hat man an diesen heutigen
Tag nicht gefunden weder frakteile noch
weitere Leichen
menschliche Überreste nichts dergleichen
alle die Funde rühren jetzt her vom
Samstag als wie gesagt sehr viele
fraktale sichtbar waren und die Behörden
hier auch eben zwei Menschen bergen
konnten zwei tote Menschen nach wie vor
läuft die Suche nach den vier weiteren
Opfern und natürlich besonders nach dem
Wrack der Maschine denn hier könnten
sich alle möglichen Rätsel verbergen
natürlich auch das Rätsel warum diese
Maschine hier abgestürzt ist warum sie
gegen die Wasseroberfläche gekracht ist
wahrscheinlich mit hohem Tempo man sieht
auch teilweise an den Praktikern die
geborgen wurden wie groß die Wucht des
Aufpralls gewesen sein muss wenn man
hier sieht wie Metallteile praktisch
fast zerknüllt wirken zusammengedrückt
verbogen wirklich eine unglaubliche
Wucht und natürlich auch aufgrund der
Aussagen dieses einen Polizisten dass
man hier auch kleinere Leichenteile
gefunden hat das deutet darauf hin dass
hier ein wirklich furchtbarer
schrecklicher Absturz passiert ist ja
aber du sagst das ist sind auch sehr
viele Fragen offen in diesem Fall können
die Behörden sich denn inzwischen
wenigstens erklären wieso es nie einen
Notruf gab
ja es gibt viele flugexperten die hier
sich die Flugdaten ansehen und es gibt
eigentlich nur die Flugdaten die vom
Flugradar gemeldet worden es gibt hier
keine Blackbox die jetzt gefunden wurde
die man ausgewertet hätte und aufgrund
dieser Daten die man hat sieht man dass
es ein sehr eigenartiger Flug war
mehrmals mit einem Absinken mit einem
dramatischen Absinken mit teilweise
verschiedenen Geschwindigkeiten die
allerdings erklärbar sein könnten am
Ende dann jedoch vom Radar verschwunden
die Maschine das Problem was man hat
dass man hier offensichtlich den genauen
Ort nicht weiß und deshalb diese Suche
so aussichtslos derzeit erscheint man
sieht hier es wurden Bilder
veröffentlicht von der Küstenwache wo
man eben sieht wie diese Schiffe
unterwegs sind und man sieht diese
Weiten des Ozeans und man kann sich
ungefähr vorstellen wie schwierig es ist
hier etwas zu finden natürlich würden
hier wahrscheinlich spezialflugzeuge und
Spezialgeräte gebraucht werden um mit
möglicherweise mit Radar oder
Ultraschall das fragt auch spüren zu
können auf dem Meeresboden das Meer ist
hier nicht besonders tief all das ist
den Behörden bisher nicht gelungen und
man muss schon dazu sagen es klingt ein
wenig enttäuschend wenn man hört dass am
heutigen Tag nur ein einziges
Suchflugzeug unterwegs ist allerdings
die Behörden sagen es geht morgen weiter
es geht weiter wenn hier die Sonne
aufgeht 5:30 Uhr starten die ersten
Maschinen aus San José und es wird
gehofft dass man hier doch den
Angehörigen ein wenig Klarheit bringen
kann erstens durch das Bergen möglicher
weiterer Toter und natürlich auch die
große Frage die geklärt werden muss wie
ist es zu diesem tragischen Absturz
gekommen ja was genau passierte in den
Minuten vor dem Absturz und warum wurde
kein Notruf abgesetzt ja der Todesflug
der mcfit-familie er wirft viele Fragen
auf
am Freitag gegen 15 Uhr 23 Uhr Ortszeit
verlässt die Maschine das mexikanische
Touristenziel palenke und fliegt
planmäßig Richtung Zielflughafen Limone
in Costa Rica die Reiseflughöhe beträgt
rund 10.000 Meter um 17.14 geht die
Maschine stark in den Sinkflug um 17:52
Uhr befindet sich der kleinflieger nur
noch rund 220 Meter über dem Meer zieht
noch einmal hoch ändert den Kurs nur
zwei Minuten später reist der Kontakt ab
69 Meter über der Meeresoberfläche bei
einer Geschwindigkeit von 441 km/h
laut dem was Experten mir berichtet
haben ist ein solcher Absturz ins mehr
als würde man auf eine Betonfläche
aufschlagen bisher haben wir kleinere
Trümmerteile gefunden aber die Suche ist
sehr intensiv wir möchten die
Leichenbergen um den Familien Frieden zu
geben
die Rettungsmaßnahmen der Küstenwache
von Costa Rica müssen wegen der
einbrechenden Dunkelheit und schlechten
Wetterbedingungen abgebrochen werden
doch am Samstag finden die
Rettungsmannschaften eine Männerleiche
sowie den Körper eines Kindes welches
Tod auf dem Meer treibt es soll sich um
den sechsjährigen Aaron handeln
doch was wirklich an Bord geschah bleibt
ungewiss noch neun Minuten vor dem
Absturz geht Rainer Schaller Berichten
zufolge letztmals bei Whatsapp online ob
er noch eine Nachricht schreibt ist
nicht bekannt fakt ist die Maschine
hatte keinen Notruf abgesetzt auch ein
Notrufsignal welches bei einem Aufprall
automatisch gesendet wird gab es nicht
bei uns im Studio Peter Brandl Pilot und
flugzeugexperte schön dass Sie bei uns
sind Herr Brandl wie sicher ist so ein
Privatjet im Normalfall sehr sicher das
ist ein komplexes Flugzeug das ähnliche
Standards hat wie ein großes Flugzeug
das ist tausendfach bewährtes Ding ist
sicher an und für sich schauen wir mal
ein bisschen auf diesen Flug was da
passiert sein könnte natürlich alles nur
spekulativ aber sie haben viel Erfahrung
die Reiseflughöhe wirft Fragen auf also
wenn wir mal sehen um 1:14 Uhr da
verließ dann die Maschine die
Reiseflughöhe von 10.000 Metern ist
gesunken mit 561 km/h dann ist man fünf
Minuten auf dieser Höhe geblieben und
dann sehen wir es wieder ein plötzlicher
Singflug und dann der Absturz wie
erklären Sie sich das im Prinzip sie
können sich das so vorstellen man wird
an den Flughafen ran geleitet und
irgendwann fängt man das Sinken an ja
und die Reiseflug ist völlig normal dann
geht man in so ein initial decent und
man kriegt eine man kriegt eine Clemens
also eine Freigabe auf eine bestimmte
Höhe und wenn man da ist levelt man
erstmal aus also geht wieder in den
normal
völlig normal und dass man dann weiter
sinkt dann kommt meistens die nächste
Freigabe sinken sie jetzt auf die und
die Höhe auch das ist an und für sich
normal was nicht so normal ist ist das
kein Notruf abgesetzt wurde welche
Gründe könnte es dafür geben
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten die
Möglichkeit eins ist dass der Pilot das
war in dem Fall nur ein Pilot wirklich
so beschäftigt ist dass er gerade
irgendwas versucht zu lösen und dann
setze ich natürlich eine andere
Priorität also wenn ich gerade großes
Problem habe die zweite Möglichkeit ist
dass denen überhaupt nicht bewusst war
dass sie sich in einer Notlage befunden
haben also dass die davon ausgegangen
sind dass alles normales und dann setze
ich natürlich kein Notfall das könnte
auch dafür sprechen dass diese Maschine
ja viele Flughäfen die sie hätte
ansteuern können auf dem Weg einfach hat
liegen lassen auch wieder eine
Möglichkeit offensichtlich wusste man
nicht dass irgendwas nicht in Ordnung
ist sonst hätte man ja wahrscheinlich
versucht einen anderen Flughafen der
schneller zu erreichen ist anzufliegen
die Frage ist auch es kann auch sein
dass das alles in Ordnung war also der
der Rückflug ist normal dass da sehe ich
keine Auffälligkeiten ja die sind die
haben die sind dahin geflogen dann
relativ kurz vor Schluss drehen sie eben
auf diesen endanflugkurs ein und da ist
es ja im Prinzip auch passiert nun haben
wir jetzt auch kein schlechtes besonders
schlechtes Wetter gehabt in dieser Phase
keine Turbulenzen die jetzt darauf
hindeuten könnten dass irgendwie so
etwas passiert sein könnte was glauben
Sie jetzt einfach mal aus ihrer Sicht
wenn sie sich das anschauen was wäre
denn eine Möglichkeit also das ist
natürlich spekulativ das wissen wir ich
kann mir zwei Sachen ganz grundsätzlich
vorstellen eine Sache ist ganz banal
dass die schlicht dann einfach ein
Autopilot der singt auf eine Höhe und
normalerweise levelt er dann aus also
der geht in Normalflug über diese Höhe
da gibt es einen Alarmsystem das kann
man einstellen das kann sein dass das
schlicht und einfach vergessen worden
ist und wenn die auf 2000 Fuß sind 700
Meter wenn ihr dahin gesunken worden
sind und der Flieger hört dann nicht auf
zu sinken ja meine sind gerade von 1500
Fuß pro Minute habe jetzt noch 30
Sekunden habe ich noch habe ich ein
bisschen mehr als eine Minute also wenn
ich das vergessen habe und bin kurz
abgelenkt Punkt 1 Punkt 2 ist das war
halt auch nur ein Pilot das Flugzeug
darf von Single Hand also von einem
Pilot geflogen werden es macht aber Sinn
zwei zu haben weil dann können wir uns
gegenseitig überprüfen ne das ist eine
zweite Variante dritte Möglichkeit die
man nicht ausschließen kann ist das ganz
kurz vor der Landung das war ja wirklich
sehr weit unten und im anderen Flug mit
dem Piloten was war das der warum auch
immer so ein medizinisches Problem hatte
man weiß es nicht
und dass deswegen eben wirklich ganz
kurz vor Schluss er eine bestimmte
Handlung nicht ausgeführt hat die hätte
ausführen sollen Peter Brandl Pilot und
flugexperte vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung hier bei uns in der Sendung
da schauen wir noch mal auf reiner
Schaller sein Leben das war ja wirklich
geprägt von vielen Höhen und Tiefen er
war ein erfolgreicher selfmade Millionär
er war aber eben auch das Gesicht der
Duisburger Loveparade die ja am Ende
wirklich dramatisch ausgeht für ihn auch
traumatisches Erlebnis nachdem er sich
selbst Verbot zu lachen
ein reiner Schaller der lacht und feiert
und das Leben genießt
und ein reiner Schaller der still ist in
sich gekehrt ernst
wir müssen die Frage beantworten wer für
diese Katastrophe verantwortlich ist
ich muss das wissen
[Musik]
sie Katastrophe gemeint ist die
Loveparade 2010 in Duisburg der
Nachmittag des 24 Juli an dem 21
Menschen bei einer Massenpanik Sterben
zu Tode getrampelt in einem betontunnel
der Wendepunkt im Leben von Rainer
Schaller der sympathische self-made-mann
der fitnessvisionär der mit seiner
attraktiven Freundin Christiane
schikorski auf roten Teppichen um die
Wette strahlt ein Typ voller Tatendrang
der Mitte der 90er das Image des
uncoolen Kraftsports aufmöbelt seine
Idee bezahlbare Leibesertüchtigung für
jedermann und zwar rund um die Uhr
1997 eröffnet der gebürtige Bamberger in
einer alten Möbelhalle sein erstes
Studio McFit die nächsten 25 Jahre wird
aus der RSG Group ein erfolgsimperium
1000 Studios in 48 Ländern weltweit die
Nummer eins im Bereich Fitness intensive
weiterer Marken von Modelabel bis McFit
Modelagentur
Schallers Vermögen geschätzte 250
Millionen Euro mit diesen Tatendrang
geht Schaller 2010 als Veranstalter auch
daran die Loveparade aufzumöbeln heute
weit über eine Millionen Menschen das
Wetter ist herrlich es wird nicht regnet
es wird trocken bleiben die Sonne ist
draußen alles passt die Vorzeichen
stimmen wir haben halbes Jahr intensiv
gearbeitet Schaller kann nicht wissen
dass der Tag zur Katastrophe wird die
Anhörungen und die Suche nach
Verantwortlichen setzen ihm zu
Betroffenheit Trauer selbst Vorwürfe
viele Jahre lang gibt es kein Foto auf
dem Rainer Schaller lacht
jetzt sprechen wir mit jemandem der ihn
tatsächlich persönlich kennengelernt hat
nämlich Bildreporter Daniel Böcking
schönen guten Morgen wann genau hast du
schon kennengelernt was war für ein Typ
ich habe ihn kennengelernt tatsächlich
kurz vor der Loveparade 2010 auch schon
in den ganzen Vorbereitungen und ich
fand die damals wahnsinnig beeindruckend
weil es natürlich so ein selfmade
Millionär war so ein Macher auch vom Typ
her ja ziemlich auffällig mit jeder
Menge auffälligen Schmuck aber er hat
auch immer was sehr verbindliches also
ich glaube er hat mich auf der einen
Seite beeindruckt war aber auch so
gegenseitiger Respekt den wir
miteinander hatten und dann haben wir ja
auch tatsächlich diese Tage der
Loveparade sehr sehr intensiv
miteinander verlebt weil ich zufällig
eigentlich auch als Bildreporter da
selbst vor Ort war es war ja ein
einschneidendes ganz dramatisches
Erlebnis auch für ihn als Menschen für
den Menschen Schaller wie hat denn das
persönlich auch verändert
na ich hätte auf der einen Seite ja
immer diese diese Bildreporter Distanz
ganz normal ich glaube wir hatten sehr
schnell geschafft Vertrauen zueinander
zu fassen und deswegen
war er relativ offen auch in diesen
Tagen danach man kann natürlich sagen es
war mir mal wahnsinnig wichtig nicht so
viel von sich selbst preiszugeben weil
er immer gesagt hat es in 21 Menschen
gestorben und das ist die Tragödie nicht
mein Leben oder sowas aber es war auf
der einen Seite rein optisch ganz leicht
zu erkennen weil er war vorher so ein
bisschen Paradiesvogel mit viel Schmuck
das hat er alles abgelegt er hat später
auch mal gesagt er hat sich selbst
verboten jahrelang zu lachen weil das
wäre natürlich auf der einen Seite nicht
angemessen gewesen er wollte aber auch
bloß kein Foto von sich haben wo er
irgendwie strahlt als derjenige der
zumindest moralisch verantwortlich ist
für den Tod von so vielen Menschen und
was uns so Stück weit verbunden hat
glaube ich war dass wir beide uns sehr
mit mit so großen Fragen dann auch
beschäftigt haben und er hat mir später
gesagt dass er in diesem ganzen Prozess
er hat immer gesagt er hat wieder beten
gelernt also er hat tatsächlich auch so
für sich zum Glauben gefunden und hat
glaube ich da ein bisschen Halt gefunden
glaube ich sonst irgendwann wahnsinnig
wirst wenn du das nicht auf den Knien
erledigst hast du ihm das wirklich
abgenommen war das echt oder war das nur
eine PR-Nummer für draußen es war so
eine ganz beliebte Frage weil man
natürlich immer direkt das Gefühl hatte
Schauspiel und ich glaube tatsächlich
Rainer Schaller kann ich nur sagen was
meinem Empfinden war war jemand der auf
der einen Seite hoch professionell war
er hatte damals sehr schnell eine
Krisenkommunikation aufgebauten Agentur
die ihn da beraten hat also er war sehr
sehr bedacht darauf zu sagen dass er die
moralische Verantwortung übernimmt aber
nicht die juristische oder den Satz hat
er niemals dazu gesagt aber es war
natürlich klar dass er
niemals gesagt hätte ich allein war
dafür verantwortlich aber gleichzeitig
wollte er für die Angehörigen da sein
und mehr erschien das ehrlich auf der
einen Seite er war zutiefst betroffen
und er war komplett aufgewühlt und hat
auch immer wieder gesagt sein Leben wie
es vorher war das ist einfach vorbei auf
der anderen Seite war er natürlich auch
Geschäftsmann hat wahnsinnig viele
Mitarbeiter und er hätte jetzt nicht
gesagt ich gehe jetzt einfach mal so ins
Gefängnis und sage ich bin juristisch
für all das Verantwortlichen am Ende war
ja tatsächlich ist es so ausgegangen
dass er niemals belangt worden ist und
das haben wir natürlich wahnsinnig viele
Menschen sehr sehr übel genommen wie hat
er dann wieder zurückgefunden in sein
altes Leben wenn es denn möglich war
oder zumindest so dass er wieder lachen
konnte
wir hatten regelmäßig oder wir hatten
also sehr sehr oft und sehr sehr tiefen
Kontakt aber nicht jede Woche einmal
telefoniert das heißt wie genau sein
sein Lebenswandel später war kann man am
allerbesten eigentlich sehen wenn man
sich ein bisschen die Bilder auch
anschaut dass er irgendwann tatsächlich
so nach sechs sieben Jahren sieht man
die wieder lächelnd auf Fotos manchmal
gibt es später auch welche wo er
tatsächlich wieder lacht aber ich war
habe ihn das letzte Mal getroffen das
ist auch schon einige Jahre mittlerweile
wieder her aber da war er nach wie vor
so er hat das nie abgeschüttelt er hat
das nie verarbeitet und die Loveparade
ist zum Teil von ihm geworden aber
natürlich hat er irgendwann wieder
angefangen nach vorne zu schauen und er
ist wieder die schnellen Autos gefahren
und er hat die Motorräder geliebt und
hat Freunde zum Grillen eingeladen also
ich glaube es ist eine ganz normale
Entwicklung dass es den Menschen
Schaller so wie es ihn vor der
Loveparade gegeben hat nicht mehr
gegeben hat dass in das tatsächlich sehr
betroffen hat dass er sehr professionell
damit umgegangen ist aber dann natürlich
auch irgendwann angefangen hat wieder
nach vorne zu schauen
danke dass du diese ganz persönlichen
Einblicke mit uns geteilt hast vielen
Dank
[Musik]